that joining us now we have uh reince
priebus is with us
friend of the program for our rnc chair
former governor
mike huckabee you know there's a woman
that's running
for governor in arkansas right now that
i think is going to be a better governor
than you were i hope you don't take it
personally
i don't take it personally there's
probably some talk show host out there
that's going to take your place someday
and they'll be better than you
too sean i'm thrilled with my daughter
well done she's well deserved great come
back
always that's what made you great on the
presidential debate speech
all right right let me tell you
something yeah go ahead i'll go ahead
no you go governor go finish well i just
want to say this
i'm waiting for uh swalwell and i'm
waiting for
good old schiff to come out and say we
finally found evidence of russian
collusion and it wasn't with donald
trump it was with joe biden
because he is given a gift that keeps on
giving to vladimir putin and the
russians
and he's done it at the expense of a lot
of american workers including a bunch of
them who live in my home state of
arkansas in the pipeline
that he decided he was going to shut
down reince
i think the governor makes a good point
because
it was joe biden that's given them a
waiver
he's not given america the same waiver
so he lied when he said it was about
climate change or else he wouldn't have
given or granted the waiver
uh it was obama that said i'll have more
flexibility after the election
it was hillary that bought the dirty
dossier with russian misinformation
and handed over believe it or not
uranium
to the russians when we have a shortage
of uranium
but they did get a nice kick back to the
clinton foundation
right well they i've always heard that
the worst thing about betrayal
sean is that it usually doesn't come uh
that it doesn't come from your enemies
right so
and certainly you wouldn't expect it to
come from the president by the way but
president biden also
said on april 15th from the press room
uh that he opposed the pipeline blinken
said during his confirmation which i
think
has been forgotten lincoln had testified
under oath
that he opposed this russian pipeline
even the european parliament voted 581-5
opposed to the pipeline the german
parliament
opposed it so you're right so biden
shuts down keystone
he uh he the russian hackers
shut down the biggest commercial
pipeline in america we're all waiting
in line for a week for gas and then he
lifts the sanctions and you're right
it's not america first
and it's russia first and it's tons of
money
flowing back to russia i think the
governor's right i don't
who knows what putin has on biden i
don't know
but certainly it's very bizarre when
people testify under oath
that they're going to oppose something
and then they turn around four months
later and they lift the sanctions and
elbow bump the uh lavrov
in reykjavik iceland uh just before the
sanctions are lifted
pretty wild stuff he could have sent in
zero experience hunter
got a his company 3.5 million from the
first lady of moscow a russian oligarch
maybe hunter could have helped
actually do something productive for
once uh governor let me ask you this
because
energy is the lifeblood of the world's
economy now our allies are dependent on
russia
and we've now taken ourselves out of the
game artificially raising the costs on
every american and every good
we buy in any store we we shop at
now if he's a hostile actor and it's a
hostile regime russia
why would we give so much power and
control
over the economies of our allies to him
what if he decides to turn the spigot
off one day because he's in a bad mood
there's been rumors out there that his
enemies get uh
quite interesting treatment
sean there's three things a country has
to be able to do to stay free
it has to be able to feed itself
therefore its farmers are important
it has to be able to fight for itself
meaning it has to be able to manufacture
its own weapons of self-defense
that's why parts and manufacturing are
critical we can't outsource that to
china or somewhere else
and the third thing we've got to be able
to fuel ourselves if we can't supply our
own energy needs and by the way
in the u.s we've got 300 plus years of
oil and gas at our disposal
but if we don't use what we have and if
we aren't the greatest producer in the
world
then we're just simply going to have to
wait and decide which country is going
to allow us to have enough
energy to maintain our liberty that's
why this is not a minor political
skirmish
this is truly a fight for our very
existence and freedom as a country
you know i'm an all the above guy reince
priebus somebody comes up with
an invention we can get you know all the
energy we need
uh and it's inexpensive and
that that would transform the entire
world
i'm all open to that but it doesn't
exist right now
so in the meantime the oil the gas
the coal that's what and nuclear we
can't touch that either
so it's the lifeblood of the world's
economy now my question is
so if that's the case when we take
ourselves out of the production
side of this we artificially reduce
supply
that means we're raising costs and we're
raising dependency
and now we are being harmed potentially
because a lot of countries can dictate
what the price will be
and we are beholden to them we weren't
under donald trump for the first time in
75 years
why would he give that up
well it it it's a wild thing as far as
what's going on you think about the same
thing with steel and aluminum and what
the governor said what you're talking
about
these are national security issues steel
aluminum manufacturing
gas oil and you know this is what people
when you talk about the american people
when they start to see
the reality of the biden economy when
they're waiting in line
um for gas when they when when their
businesses can't hire people because
it's easier and more convenient for
people to stay home and collect a check
than it is to go back to work these are
the life the once in a lifetime
lessons on what it means to be a
conservative
market-based economy in america are very
few opportunities to do it can you
imagine
if donald trump's first few months in
office
where his first actions were to shut
down our
gas and oil turn on turn on russia's
gas and oil fist pump lavrov
in iceland and call it a day and have
americans
wait in line to fill up their gas tanks
it's it's incredible but
this is where we are it's a new america
it's not going to end well putting
russia first and helping russia get rich
again
that's about as dumb as the iranian deal
dropping 150 billion
in cash and other currencies on the
tarmacs for the muellers in iran
the number one state sponsor of terror
and getting nothing
in exchange anyway reince priebus
governor thank you both
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now